growing up when did art begin to matter
to you
i really didn't know much about
you know art or the process of
expressing oneself creatively but one
day i was in second grade and
i went to after school daycare right
and there was a rock painting contest
and so we were told to go get a rock
and and paint the rock so i got a rock
and i took the rock home and i just
looked at it
and then the next day i went out and got
some paint with my grandma and i painted
this rock
and um i turned it into the
rock painting competition and i won
and um i think
um grew up in a really dysfunctional
home right
where it wasn't common to be praised
you know it wasn't commonplace to um be
applauded for something and
when i won and i got called up everyone
was clapping i'm like what is
what is this why are they why are these
people staring at me and why are they
clapping
and i realized that oh people like art
people like art and then the next year
there was an origami contest at the
public library
and i entered that
and i did an origami sculpture of six
ducks
and i won and
when they announced me as a winner i
went up again in the same thing people
were clapping and smiling
and i'm saying to myself why are people
looking at me
why are people smiling why are people
clapping
and i wrote oh people like art
and that's when i when i began to
understand
how much joy art can bring to other
people
and also to the artist him him or
herself
so that's when i discovered art oh can i
share one more story
so um as i mentioned i
come from a very non-traditional
family kind of dysfunctional and people
it's very fractured family
and i really feel like art saved me art
was my therapy
so um and it was challenging
for me to find connection with my mother
and uh one day i came home
i was in fourth grade and there is my
mom sitting on the porch
with this hippie artist this is like um
late 70s right and um
there's like maybe 50 to 60 paintings on
the front lawn against the walls
and my mom looked really happy
to be sitting in the shade
on our porch with this hippie artist
with all this beautiful artwork
and then i realized this is so i've had
three turning points about art the first
one was
the rock painting competition the second
one was the origami
the third one was i've never seen my
mother look so happy
she really likes art and my mother was
prone to um
i'll just say it my mother was prone to
depression okay
and um she had a lot of strife in her
life and
she wasn't the happiest person but when
i saw her with
these 50 or 60 pieces of art this artist
she looked complete to me
and i think maybe one of the reasons why
i really continue to engage in the art
is because
i know my mother likes art and i never
quite felt
you know the mother-son thing it just
was never quite complete for me
and maybe that's maybe part of my
reason for pursuing the arts is because
of my own
mama trauma which i which i own but it's
it's it's part of my journey i don't
feel like a victim so those are the
three
kind of turning points for me about
art and what art means to the artist
and to those around him or her the other
thing is i never put those three things
together before
oh wow the rock and the origami and my
mother
until i got here because you helped me
arrive to that place
oh wow see that's part of your
collective gift that you can create that
space
for people to really think openly with
that fear of judgment
because i never i never talked about art
i've never been asked that question and
i never thought of it in that way
so thank you wow i thought that was like
a story
of yours that you knew i've never told
that before i've never even put those
dots together
wow so i just had a follow up with it i
just wanted to okay
okay um did you ever find out who the
artist was like who's
like was this person with the long hair
is
no i um all i know is his first name was
sam
i asked my mother about it um at
christmas two years ago
she um recalls that afternoon when i
came
from school for some reason my other
brothers and sisters didn't come home
that day it was just me
so but i don't know who the artist was
but she did buy
two pieces of art one was
a sun an image of a sun
but the sun was stretched and it was
sort of
vertically integrated and of course me
you know being kind of love star i was
thinking well maybe she got the sun
because i'm
the sun i don't know if that's true
maybe that's just wishful
wish fantasy um
and the other one was um
an image of a boat on a very
calm lake and um
i thought it was interesting that she
placed
the the painting of the sun very close
to my room
and then the image of the long belt on
the empty lake
she put in her bedroom because she often
told me that she felt like
you know that song simon garfunkel
i'm a rock or i am an island yeah yeah
she i think that opinion was about her
need
for solitude and and being alone
but those they're still up in the house
those two paintings and i always look at
them and
have a recall about the moment when my
mom was with the artist and
when she bought them
so i think maybe in that moment
you know critically thinking about my
mother's choices the sun
and the boat i also think the boat may
have had to do with her father
who was a who was into sailing
i think i started engaging in critical
thinking about
art that's visual you know so i think my
mom
my mom really did like artists and she
was a little bit easier on me
at times when i would excel in the arts
you know oscar wilde says that um
everyone is afraid of their mother
that's what asked about said
and in some sense i think that's true
but um i'm going through a phase of my
life where my mother and i are talking
more openly about things and we're
filing
um common stepping stones upon which we
can
stand on together and find
reconciliation and find
understanding because i think on our
journey
we struggle to find connection with
others we struggle to
to love but we also struggle to be loved
by the people that should love us right
and it's an it's an ongoing it's an
ongoing thing but
i think the three moments i talked about
actually inform
my filmmaking proclivities
if that makes sense do you remember one
of the first films that you saw
that really uh kind of hooked you in
hope for your love of movies
you know um
i watched oliver twist i don't like
musicals at all like i think
oh who stops in the middle of preparing
a sandwich to sing a song
i have no patience for musicals but
oliver
so when i grew up um we
we didn't always we didn't always have
enough to eat
um but well we did we did but
you know we didn't have carton milk we
had instant milk and
my grandmother would bring us you know
government cheese um my father was very
proud and he refused to accept any form
of welfare
like we qualified for the school lunch
tickets
and my dad said no no we're not dad why
dad
why not no we're not taking money we
don't need it
so i was hungry a lot as a child
and you know my mother and my father had
four kids
did not have the college educations my
father had a job my mother
focused on you know being a mother and
raising us but um
i related to oliver because
he was an orphan he had no family right
i had a family but i felt like i was
detached from them
and he he was hungry for food and for
love
and i found a really deep connection
with oliver twist
especially when he goes up and says
please sir i want
more they said more how dare you ask for
more food you're an
orphan in this orphanage and i watched
the film over and over again
and i started acting out scenes with my
twin brother my little brother and i
started
taking photos i didn't have a video
camera and
i think that film just my connection
with the protagonist and his
journey to find love and acceptance and
a sense of belonging
you know his need for food was really um
one thing but the deeper need was to be
loved and feel
accepted that inspired me to be
a filmmaker i started making films but
they just were with
cameras you know camera stills but i'd
piece
the photos together and i wrote down
what was going on so i started
storyboarding
at the age of nine because i saw a
leveraged list
from reading your story i think you said
that the
artist the late artist formerly known as
prince
yeah gave you some advice and you had
just moved to hollywood i guess and
yeah so um i actually love telling this
story so um
i moved to los angeles before i got
accepted to film school
and um i just figured if i don't get
into usc
or ucla if i i'll you know
go assist the director or get a job at a
production company over the studio so
i um the second day i was in la i got an
internship with a company called
propaganda films
and on my second day of the job um
a casting director says hey um
what's your name and i said alex she
said oh her name is lisa fields and she
said um
would you like to be a stand-in for a
famous rock star i'm like
well who is it and she said well i can't
tell you i said nah i don't want to be a
stand-in because i want to be behind the
camera so i went back to my boss stephen
price and
i said hey um lisa fields wants me to be
a stand-in for a rock star she won't
tell me who it is and
i don't want to do it and he said why i
said because i want to be a director i
don't want to be in front of the camera
i want to be behind the camera he said
you have to do it
you've never been on a professional film
set so i raced back
and she was on the phone ready to hire
somebody i said i'll do it i'll do it
she said okay
so the next day i'm on the set and
the dp says okay alex you can leave now
and i turn around
and i'm face to face with prince and
i'm like i really wasn't a big prince
fan at the time but i was looking down
at him
and our noses were like this far apart
i'm like wow
you got four inch heels on and i'm
taller than you
and he just laughed and he goes can we
switch places and i said sure
so um anyway we were told not to talk to
prince he said do not talk to him
but he would talk to me and on day six i
got my letter of acceptance from usc
and um my roommate got the letter
and she said i have something really
important to give you i said okay well
i'm in downtown l.a and
i'm on this music video should can you
bring it so she gave me the letter i
opened it up and i went
into the set and i said i was really
excited i said i got at usc film school
and everyone started clapping and prince
said
i'm like what he goes come here i'm like
well what did i do
so he said so you're going to be a
filmmaker
i said yes he said let me hear you say
that
i said say what he said let me hear you
say you're going to be a filmmaker
and i said i'm going to be a filmmaker
and he said i want you to
listen closely there are four roles i
want you to consider abiding by
if you are going to pursue filmmaking in
this town
i said okay so he said first one always
he pointed up out
always remember god the creator always
remember god
and your creator number two always
remember where you come from
because when you forget where you come
from you die as an artist
and then number three was um
break the rules if you follow the rules
you're going to be bullied and you're
going to fade fast
and number four was always give back
you must give back as an artist
and i said okay and he said repeat
repeat what i said and i did
i call these my four purple cornerstones
remember god where you come from um
never forget uh where you come from
i'm sorry let me start over i will
always remember
the four i call them my four purple
cornerstones
remember god and the creator never
forget where you come from
break the rules and always always give
back and he said grace is really
important in your journey
so after he tested me on the four
you know core principles he told me he
told rosie gaines backup singer he said
rosie
pray for this brother that he does not
go down the dark path
he needs to stay on the path of light
so rosie gaines took my hands
placed them on prince's piano
and pray made a prayer a protection that
i wouldn't be seduced by the dark side
you know
well all the what prince called the
fleshly temptations and
she said this is serious we are praying
for you and after she prayed prince said
amen
wow and he said don't forget what i told
you i said i won't
so imagine that
is a priceless encounter that cannot be
measured
i just moved to la i just i finished my
undergraduate work at santa barbara
for him to take the time to tell me
these things
and share with me his four core
principles and for him to ask his backup
singer rosie gaines to pray for me
i never forget this and
one of the reasons why when i decided to
move forward with making fy films a
non-profit
i rummaged through my mind i remember
prince saying always give back
and he helped me
i don't think i'd be talking about fy
films if princeton tell me this about
giving back
because it seems like all four things
you've incorporated the purple
cornerstones
that sounds like that's all i tried to
and then the second part of the story is
so when prince died right they did a
tribute concert
for him and uh i called the organizers
and i said hi
um my name is alex munoz and prince gave
me some really good advice back in the
day
i will do anything i will sweep the
streets i will
sell popcorn i will sell hot dogs so
i'll be an usher
i'll do security i just want to in my
own way pay tribute to this great artist
because he held he gave me some advice
that i'll never ever forget
so they said we'll call you right back
and what happened was
two hours later they called back and
they said we googled you and you're a
filmmaker why don't you do a film
celebrating prince and i said well the
concert's 10 days away i can't possibly
make a good enough film
and i said how what if i document it so
i went to document this
prince tribute concert and
the very first interview i did is is
happened to be in the same exact spot
when prince told me the
four purple cornerstones it was like oh
my god this is where
prince told me to remember god
remember where you come from break the
bulls and always get back
and i felt really inspired
like my body was like trembling because
i was you could feel his presence
in that area was the concert was right
in front of
la city hall which is where they shot
the video how uncanny is that
then um
i went out to the audience and
interviewed some people about the
concert and stevie wonder does this
amazing
rendition of purple rain so i'm trying
to get backstage to interview stevie
and i can't get to him and the guards
are saying you can't talk to stevie he
doesn't want to be bothered
so one of my fy film alumni from hawaii
adrian kelly sees me and says hey um
alex what are you doing here and i said
oh
i think i told you when i taught fy
films
that when i taught the film workshop
that my first experience on the film set
was being princess standard he said yeah
yeah
but what are you doing here i said i'm
doing a documentary he said well why do
you look mad i said because
stevie gave the best performance and i
want to interview him and they won't let
me get backstage and he said
oh i could help you and i said adrian
that's really nice to you but you can't
help me
he said alex i could help you he goes in
the back comes back and he says come on
takes me stevie wonder stevie wonder's
nephew
oh wow so
wow i felt like it was full circle so i
mean i got like chicken skin right now
because prince tells me
the importance of giving back i'm there
to do a documentary about this concert
i can't get to stevie it turns out one
of my alumni
never told me even stevie wonder's
nephew
gets me backstage because i believe i
had access to stevie and all the
princess backup singers and all the
princess backup dancers
because if i didn't teach that fyi film
workshop in hawaii
i would have met adrian and then two
years later i see adrian at this concert
and he gets me backstage that's
karma that is oh i'm doing what i'm
supposed to be doing
and i told adrian i said why didn't you
ever tell me
you were stevie wonder's nephew he said
i don't know you know munoz
i don't want people my family we don't
want people to like us just because
we're related to stevie so we just
but but you earned it because you've
come to our birthday parties and our
voltage live parties and you never asked
any questions and
you showed us love anyway so okay now
you know
so i mean what a blessing right that
oh my gosh one of my alumni is stevie
wonder's nephew and little did i know
that two and a half years later i would
need him
to complete my doc right and you're in
the same spot
where you first met prince so it was a
music video back in the day yes in front
of l.a city hall yeah
wow so my my doc is called um
purple dots and it's short it's just
about how i moved to la and prince gave
me this advice and then how um
you know 18 years later i'm doing this
documentary at his
tribute concert and how my first
interview was in the same
spot where i met him and how
turns out one of my alumni is stevie
wonder's nephew
and then i can do get the interviews i
need
that's its own movie yeah that's the
second part of it
wow i have a feeling like a lot of stuff
like that happens to you though
is that true that you just have like
this amazing synchronicities or
maybe i'm i'm wrong i don't know i just
feel like you have a lot of that that
happens to you yeah i think i um
i people i often share this stuff with
people or i put it on my blog and people
say why does all this magical stuff
happen to you i don't think anything
i don't think i see or witness magic
more than anybody else but i do pay
attention
and i think i have a heightened
sense of awareness because where i grew
up i had to really be aware of what was
going on
who's going to act out who's going to
become angry who is going to go hostile
and because of that i really pay
attention also
writers and directors have to have super
sharp observational skills so i just
i pay attention but i don't think i'm
anyone special or i don't have
the creator's favor just that i i do
pay attention and they always say with
intuition like we all have it i think
some people have it more
developed even though we all have that
ability to just
right just from being super aware hyper
aware of surroundings and
someone's mood or what you know what
will somebody be a danger or
whatever right yeah
wow that's but i don't even know how i
never would have imagined that
one of my alumni would help me make a
better documentary film
and i was i met him because i was giving
back because prince told me
asked me to prince challenged me to give
back and i did and
as a result i have a better doc about
him
right and then that person it came full
circle
yeah that's a powerful story
yeah wow fyi
films by youth inside that is your
non-profit
yes do you remember the day that you not
just
you know apply for the the non-profit
status but that you actually came up
with the idea
to do it um yeah i wish i could say yeah
i had this great idea to teach
filmmaking to incarcerated youth but it
actually was um
a result of as a consequence of my
my um encounter with a group of um
community activists
when i did my first movie about the la
riots
for showtime which investigated the
civil unrest following the rod of king
verdict
we screened the film at first amy church
and
leaders from the latino community
korean-american community
african-american community and also lapd
people were there
to have a panel discussion and the
screening was shut down by a group of
about 20
22 young black activists who said um
f hollywood you guys don't offer any
jobs training
or workforce development we have all
these young brothers and sisters who
want to get in you just come in here and
make your films and don't talk to us
what needs to happen for our people from
our community to enter your industry
and they shut the screening down for two
hours and a lot of producers left
they said you are discriminated against
people of color
and people from disadvantaged
communities this is bs
we want answers now so um it was good
that the producers
heard this it was important and
finally reverend sees somewhere he said
let's let's show the film and let's talk
more after
i went up to these um young activists
and i said hey um
i don't think it's fair to depict all
hollywood
filmmakers as uncaring i'm interested
in doing what i can they said well prove
it and i said well
how do you want me to prove it and they
said go to herman g stark
where they incarcerate the most violent
youth offenders and tell them
about your journey tell them about what
you do that you went to usc that you're
a professional filmmaker be a role model
to them
so two weeks later i go to herman g
stark
and um i'm given a unisex which is this
round
device it looks like a pager and they
said
if you feel in danger pull the pin and
within 10 seconds the swat team will
enter your room
and i'm thinking oh my god what did i
get myself into so i'm in this room full
of 35 young men mostly latino and black
covered with tattoos
ankles cuffed
a lot of sadness in their eyes a lot of
depression
and dim
dimness you know and i stopped talking
to them
and about an hour and a half into my
presentation
i leave the room to use the restroom and
i had set my favorite pair of
maui gym sunglasses on the chalkboard
for like 250
and my favorite pair of sunglasses so i
came back into the room and they were
gone
and so i just figured i'll talk about
this before i leave so at the end of the
three hour presentation i said hey guys
um
i came in here with my favorite pair of
sunglasses and i drove all around here
it took like an hour and 20 minutes i
i'd like them back but i won't tell
anybody what happened no one's going to
get in trouble so i'm going to leave the
room
you guys talk amongst yourselves and
i'll come back two minutes and
let's try to find resolutions so i left
the room went into the hallway got a
glass of water just
had quiet time and then i came back and
i said okay so
um can someone tell me where my
sunglasses are and a black and latino
youth stood up and said
mr munoz we know where your glasses are
and you could have them back under one
condition and i said what's that they
said if you promise to come back
and teach us more about filmmaking and i
said well that's not the way the real
world works you don't hold things for
ransom they get what you want
but i understand what you're saying
you're basically saying that you really
really
want to learn more about filmmaking that
would have worked with me if you just
would have said
munoz we really really want to learn
more about filmmaking please come back
this wasn't necessary
but i'm not going to hold it against you
give me my classes back so they gave
them back
and on the way home i realized that this
is a population that is very underserved
and
demonized and criminalized and neglected
and misunderstood and that's when i
decided to continue my work because
of the 20 to 25 young black activists
who disrupted the screening
at first amy church and the black and
latino youth
who took my glasses and said you can
have them back if you promise to come
back
without those those two events i
wouldn't be talking to you about fy
films
so this was in 92. or
no this was 90 this is actually
2000 2001 2001
2001. the riots were in 1992 but the
film came out years later
oh so okay and so in 2001 then that's
where it was showing at this church
yes how interesting okay but so
you know when people that's why to me
like community activists and grassroots
organizers they
they're the ones that inspired me to do
this they led me to this place i
wish i could say yeah i had this great
idea but it just happened i stumbled
into it
because of community activist and i feel
like the black and latino
ward were also activists for the for
their fellow students saying we want
more arts programming because there was
none
going on at hammond g stark at that time
and so how were you able to get it
approved
to be able to go in there like did you
come up with
did they say okay come up with sort of a
curriculum if you want yes
i had to i had to create a curriculum
and you know i obviously
i i based it off of my first semester of
usc film school
but these youth are subliterate they
write and read
at about the fifth or sixth grade level
so i realized i had to take a different
approach to how i taught filmmaking
they're also
um bored with the stagnant grammar of
mainstream cinema they don't like the
formality of it
and they really resent how how people of
color are misrepresented
they demand authenticity so i had to
come up with the with the curriculum
that was
commensurate with the academic
capacities of this population
and then i had to do all these
background checks and then i did
workshops for like another
three years and then decided to make it
into a full-fledged non-profit
and so i have so many questions um
what were some of the first things you
either wanted to discuss let's say the
first day of a program with new
new youth these are all incarcerated
youth right this isn't
okay so they're all incarcerated and how
long are most of their terms
are they until they're adults or yeah
well it depends so it
usually um in l.a county probation um
it ranges from six to 11 months
oh okay and we are what we have to do
when we pick the the staff
at the correctional facilities help us
identify and locate the right youth
because if we have a youth we have to
make sure that they're going to be there
for the whole two weeks
while we make the film and then the
other thing i i always talk to the the
leadership about at the
at the correctional facilities is i
always say don't
send me all the good kids the kids who
are like straight-a students and are
doing well
send me the back is because they're the
ones that benefit the most
in the first few days it's it's usually
rocky with the kids who are like you
know
have are more reckless and
you know the troubled kids but they end
up being the best students
so we not only want to impact the
students who are behaving well while
they're incarcerated but
the kids who society gives up on because
i don't think we should ever give up on
people
that's interesting why do you think the
quote unquote worst kids are the best
students in the end
i think i think children
and and youth
even adults act out more and act more
recklessly
when they don't feel loved i would say
that most of the students i have who um
have really had bad behavior problems
don't have any sense of love or
or sense of belonging um i wanted to
share this with you
not to be a downer but um i've been
working with this population for like 18
years and
have had fyi for since for about 14
years
and in the last year and a half we
we lost three alumni we lost three
students
um one student entered his life
by odin because he had no hope um
another student entered his life on the
day he turned 14 because he had no home
and another student
was deported to guadalajara mexico
and i i got really down about it i'm
thinking
why why is this happening like why
why did we lose three students in a
matter of a year and a half like
what could we be doing better i started
blaming myself like i should have done
more more
so i found out about um two of the
students um
i'm using fictionalized names because i
can't use real names ricardo and andrew
i was really upset about them and then
the student who got deported i call him
jose
he called me he found me on facebook and
he called me on facebook
and he said this is in the moment when i
reached the
nader of my despair i was really upset
about
losing alumni and he said hey munoz i'm
calling you from guadalajara mexico
my family got deported i said i'm really
sorry to hear that he said no
but there's a good part of the story i
said what's that he said
one of my best memories of being
incarcerated at camp gonzalez was taking
your film class
i'm teaching filmmaking to incarcerated
youth in guadalajara oh wow
that turned everything around for me
because see
we learned that when we touch people's
lives
that gives them the ability to touch
other lives so that
lifted me so one of my alumni lifted me
out of my
dark hole i fell into when i found out
about students
so the last film we did i talked about
these three students to my last group of
students and we decided to
they decided to dedicate this film
to the three students we lost it's in
memory of them
and guess what the film is about it's
about vanishing it's about people
disappearing
so um it's deep you know but but um
[Music]
sometimes there's tragedy in life and
sometimes there's pain
and sometimes they're suffering and you
learn and you grow from those things
and although i will miss you know we're
caught on andrew and my
i still
am grieving them um
i'm more inspired to work harder to help
these young people
get on a better path you know and
these people all had these things happen
that
the two that ended their lives after
they got out of
the camp yeah years after yeah
and um the interesting story the the
young man who
was with us at afterball
i was showing his film to the last group
of students i had
after ball uh last fall
and one of my students fell out of his
chair and started screaming and i'm like
what's wrong
and he said the actor in the film that's
my cousin i haven't seen him since he
died and i'm like what
he said that's my cousin and i said
okay do i need to stop the film he said
no i'm so happy to see my cousin happy
this means so much to me to see my
cousin that he did something he was a
really good actor in this film it was
called regret
it's about how we make decisions that we
regret but we learn from it
and so i ended up talking to the
student's mother
who was the aunt of the young man who
killed himself and i'd let her know
that her son really shined in this film
so the next week i went to the family's
home and screened this film for them
they never knew that he was in the film
class
they never knew he could act and the
screening became this moment of
celebration
because they were so proud of him for
for like learning all these lines and
carrying the film so this film
ended up giving everyone in his circle
of friends and family closure
and they loved the film they didn't know
he was in it
wow that's what i'm saying all these
moments
that they're just kind of like they're
like these magical like
it's almost like a higher hand is like
orchestrating it yeah
it is and i learned that hey from now on
when i screen films i have to
say hey we're screening a phone from
people who were here two years ago if
you know anyone let me know if it's
because i don't you know with
traumatized individuals you can't
one trigger will get them back on the
path of trauma
or we cannot re-traumatize people who
are traumatized and
i didn't know what was going on when
when this young man fell out of his
chair and was screaming but he was
screaming with joy
because he saw his cousin kicking ass
as an actor and carrying this film and
looking happy
and it the film ended up becoming a
healing element for the family
and they watched the film four or five
times
and we ate we ate dinner and we held
hands and we prayed
and i just realized these films are
not just important in terms of informing
lawmakers when they come up with policy
for use of disadvantaged communities
they also
affect the individual filemaker and
their families
i know off camera you were talking about
how you didn't want to blame
and i really like that because i know
it's easy to get in that mode
when something's not right and you want
to change it can you just touch on
briefly
um about your screening i know you had a
screening of you had a film that you did
right i i know you you want to stay
positive but i just thought it was
important if
you don't mind talking about yeah of
course um
thank you for leaving me here because i
think this is an important story
so in this last workshop i did with 16
incarcerated youth at camp aflo ball
on the first day the latino youth
expressed a lot of fear and concern
about
immigration policy and about
families being torn apart at the border
and about families being
you know abducted by ice and deported
and
it was very emotional for the latino
youth and then the black youth were
talking about
how upset they were that black people
were being arrested from starbucks for
having a business meeting or being
or having someone call the cops on them
because they were having a barbecue
at a park like what happened on lake
merritt in oakland
someone called the cops on a black
couple having a barbecue
and they
seemed to have a profound sense of
helplessness about their future
so in this film they decided to address
the ambivalent space between visibility
and invisibility
and about vanishing people disappearing
so i thought that was really deep and um
this film we made was
political um and
there's a character they came up with
called zoo and he represents the future
and in the film the zoo takes all the
people forgotten by
history and society and takes them to a
better place for healing where there's
no
prejudice there's no discrimination
there's equality there's peace and love
and happiness
so they came up with this fantasy place
like nirvana
so in the film this character named zeus
says
let us go to the promised land and all
the black lights you know you follow
them
so what happened was they're having some
issue right now
with violence in the
youth correctional facilities and some
of the violence is between
the youth and staff
and some people perceive the film
as a message of overthrow
and they felt that the message of the
film might
be and still might cause more
unrest um but they
one person from l.a county felt that
the the shaman character who represent
comes from the future was leading the
youth to a terrorist camp
to take over that wasn't their intention
at all
but what what's happening right now is
there's a big um
battle between folks who want to go away
from mass incarceration and go towards
diversion diversion is when
a youth is arrested instead of going to
being locked up they meet with a
guardian and a community leader
and someone from the county and say hey
instead of being incarcerated
you're going to go take this fy film
class are you going to take the
shakespearean class are you going to
take
a writing class but then there's another
part
of l.a county that totally wants mass
incarceration because they want to keep
their jobs so
we just happen to be caught up in the
middle of this
incredible storm there's a lot of
changes going on
but it was i've never had a film
screening cancelled i've never had the
plug pulled i i received a call from um
la cana probation saying we'd like to
see this film that you're going to
screen at after ball on saturday
and i said why i said i've never had
someone from upper management request to
see a film
they said we just need to see it so i
sent it to them
and four hours later they said you're
not screening this film
i i couldn't even go to the camp and
show this the film to the youth
there was some confusion about the legal
parameters of can we screen this film
but what was beautiful about it is um
the mexican-american legal defense fund
came forward naacp
urban league of america the jewish
defense league amnesty international
aclu they all came forward and said we
support you in screening the film made
by your students who were incarcerated
at camp after ball
and they want to do this big press
conference to protest i'm like no no no
let's let this unfold and we will find
resolution
and the film will be screened it's going
to be screened a lot later than we
wanted but i'm
currently working to get the film
cleared so the dust screen
but on the outs outside of the
corrections they also
were concerned about
here we have maxine waters and possibly
ridley thomas
potentially giving introductory remarks
in l.a times and
some people at upper management were not
very comfortable with that so i
understand it just was not the right
time to screen this film
and um now if if they decided the last
minute to not
allow us to screen the film on the outs
it's a violation of my students first
amendment rights
because even when one is incarcerated
one still has
freedom of speech i don't think it's
going to go there i really
believe i'm confident and hopeful that
we will be able to screen this film in
august
but something really beautiful happened
on the last day of filming
um there was some fighting amongst the
youth
about eight or nine youth um were hurt
four or five youth were hospitalized
but the 16 students in the film class
did not get involved they became
impervious to the violence around them
because they understood
they were very clear that they did not
finish their film
today there would be no film to screen
so it just shows the power of the arts
and like when you give youth goals
something to focus on they don't get
caught up in all and all that violence
so the next day at the graduation i told
them i said hey
guys you know i just wanted to commend
you we had a graduation
i want to commend you for staying
focused you didn't get caught up in all
the violence and i talked about
how does violence affect the individual
how does it affect
the your family how does it affect your
community
and then i brought up the horrible
shooting at the tree of life synagogue
in pittsburgh i said i want to explain
something to you
there was a shooting in the synagogue of
innocent people
and i want to bring this up because it
happened yesterday on the day we had
this outbreak of violence
so we talked about hate crimes and
genocide
and i've never seen anything like this
happen i think what i'm about to tell
you is probably the most beautiful
moment i've ever experienced in working
with this population
the youth asked for some butcher paper
and felted pens
and we got it for them and they
got on the floor in the gymnasium and
drew
a sympathy card for the victims of the
tree of life synagogue
in pittsburgh
and they made it and it just shows you
that when you engage these youth and
give them a chance to express themselves
and give them a sense of belonging
and acceptance and empowerment
they're able to connect with with their
own
capacity for compassion so these are 16
youth right
serving time for for crimes um
their juvenile offenders yet they are
choosing
to write a beautiful sympathy card to
victims of a hate crime in pittsburgh so
we did a talk about this film
it's called from aflab to pittsburgh
and the youth said hey emanueles can you
send the sympathy card to the priest
at the synagogue what is it called i
said well they don't have priests in
synagogues well the minister
so well it's not none it's a rabbi i've
explained to them what a rabbi was and
they said
well send it to the rabbi so i sent it i
sent it to the rabbi
and he appreciated the gesture
wow and it was it was a beautiful moment
but
it it if that doesn't show you that the
arts
can help transform lives and can help
young people
find their sense of love and compassion
and empathy for others i don't know what
is
but that that was a very profound and
meaningful moment and i will never
ever forget it i'm gonna email you both
the card they made
you have it on your facebook too right i
think i i saw it yeah
yeah it's like five by five by four feet
and um
right there's a lot of hearts and it
says we love you we're thinking of you
it's so
beautiful in its sincerity
and very genuine
and really having a concern and he said
well
how many did people die yes people died
well other families okay
i don't know i'm not a member of that
community but they
told me and my instructors that it was
very important for them to make this car
to send to the tree of life synagogue in
pittsburgh
so the screening may happen in august
yes i'm
waiting for one more clearance and
hopefully we'll do not make sure to
invite you all
love you to meet my students who came up
with this idea of
vanishing and i think what was really
hurtful for me
um was
it was our first film at l.a county
probation camp in about a year
and eight months and the youth decided
to to
um lash around this concept of vanishing
and disappearing and they came up with
this idea before they heard about the
three youth we lost
oh wow so that was profound to me and i
said i just want to let you guys know
you don't know this but
we lost three alumni two transitioned
another one was deported and for you
guys to pick up on that
is is your gift so they dedicated the
film to
the three young men and i was upset at
probation because i said do you
understand that
this is film about people vanishing and
we've had three alumni vanish
and the youth dedicated this film to
those three youth
but that that is a whole different thing
they're thinking about the stability of
their department
and i had to step back and realize that
i have to be dogged and disciplined
and get this thing cleared and screen
this and it's just not going to happen
right now i had to accept that
it was hard for me to accept i was
stressed out i was
calling on my thunders calling all the
political leaders saying i'm really
sorry
this happened and i didn't even
understand what was going on but it was
a very stressful week
i imagine how heartbreaking that is like
you have 16 youth work on this amazing
artistic profound film it was tough that
was a tough week for me because i was so
proud of my students for really
um addressing
why are black people disappearing from
starbucks and parks why are latino
families being torn apart why are
latinos being abducted and deported this
is
causing a stress munoz can we make a
film about it yes we can we did this
film
we also dedicated to the three alumni
who are no longer with us
and yet they pull the plug so it was
really
it was really tough but it's looking
better now and i'm very confident we
will screen the film
and now the good news is that all these
venues have offered their space
oh wow and now the screen is going to be
even more jam-packed because they heard
that the
first screening was cancelled but for
the youth to see it that
were the 16 filmmakers that made it that
they wouldn't be able to go to these
venues right
oh they'll go because they're all out
now oh they're all out see that's the
other good thing
because okay now we can
we'll go around or pick them up and
we'll bring them all to the screening
and we won't have to deal with the
restrictive guidelines of
probation and i think probation is kind
of back down they just
it's a very sensitive time for them
right now there's a lot of
um some violence
and there's some conflict between the
youth and the staff and
whether they should use mace or whether
they shouldn't use mason when is
diversion going to happen
what's how how are people going to make
money if
diversion comes in there's a lot of
confusion and chaos right now and we
happen to be
smack in the middle of the storm how did
you
let the the students know that the
screening was canceled
i called them and they gathered in a
small room and i had to tell them over
the phone
what was their reaction they were very
upset
and then i i went again the following
week and
i was able to screen part of the film
for two students that are very very
excited about the film
so i did get to screen some select takes
um to two of the students but the other
ones i just said hey
we're going to screen the film you will
get to see it trust me
i'm working on it so this screening that
happens
hopefully early august will be
a beautiful moment of of solidarity
and unity and triumph because wow we
finally got this film out you know
and how many screenings have you done
total since what what 2001.
oh we've done it's really difficult to
get the films cleared because you have
to get the
the courts to sign off and they had
judge and probation but we've done about
um 15 15 screenings yeah
usually they're small i prefer to screen
the films um there's two venues that
offered us their theaters
but they have like 300 to 350 seats and
when you get an audience that big it's
really hard to have an intimate
meaningful conversation
so i prefer venues that are like maybe
under 100
i find that 60 to 70 is usually a good
number because then there could be real
engagement and the power of these
screenings is yes the films are great
yes it's amazing that the youth write
direct and perform these films
but the most powerful thing is when they
get up and talk about the process of
making the film
how they learn things like discipline
focus
meeting deadlines working with people
who are different from them a lot of my
students they come from rival gangs
and i have to it's my job to make sure
that hey
we're on the same team right now so
during the pro bowl
does someone from the oakland raiders
hate on someone on the broncos because
they're in different conferences
no they're in hawaii to win the pro bowl
they're going to let go of those
differences so i call it the all-star
factor
when i break it down that way they go oh
yeah that makes sense they just let it
all go
what is day one like for the workshop
fyi workshop
what are you going over first well day
one
um my students are like this
like who are you like some hollywood guy
trying to tell us to make films and hey
we don't want to make hollywood bs films
like
we want to make real we don't want
to make
fake stuff so they are
they resist me and they
when i say we're going to make a film
they do these phobic tilts like what
is he talking about how are we going to
make a film we're locked in here
you're feeding us some bs i'm like and
then i show them films made
in the past like oh wow they become open
to
the possibility that they really can
write direct and perform in a film while
they're there
but um so the first day is just
icebreaker
it's me getting them me
learning to trust them and them learning
to trust me
and we talk about stories for instance
once
i start out every day with the story of
the
scorpion and the toe do you know that
story no so um
and they loved the story and we acted
out so there's a toad right
and he's swimming around the scorpion
comes down and says hey toad um
i need to get to the other side of the
stream and i you know i can't swim
he says please help me and the toad says
i'm not going to help you because you're
going to sting me i know what scorpions
are
the scorpion says no please toad i need
to get to the other side of the stream
because my mom's sick and i need to go
see my mom and
i promise i won't kill you until it says
no way i've heard about you
you always kill people when you get what
you want the scorpion says no i promise
i won't kill you
she said please and the scorpion starts
crying i want to see my mom
so the tug goes over and says okay so
the scorpion gets on the totes back and
they swim over and
they get on the other side of the shore
the scorpion stings this
toad and the toad dies and i
tell the youth what does this story mean
it's an aesop fable
oh you can't trust scandalous people
survive once a liar always a liar right
so why do you want to get on the back of
somebody you can't trust unless you
really know them you should not agree to
get on their back
so we we start acting out like we have
someone be the tale
someone be the scorpion then we include
like an eel who says no
don't let him go on your back then
there's an eagle saying oh no
do it do it you know and um
so we we basically explore um
storytelling and um
storytelling is very very very powerful
so the first day is pretty much about
i i let them know that they're going to
make a film they don't believe me
so then i show them films made by past
youth and they they open up to it but
they're still kind of
rigid and coiled but then once we start
doing um these improvisational where
they play
i base my teaching on hoin
hoitsinga's essay about how important
play is
for people especially youth who have
been through trauma
look if you spend most of your childhood
wondering when bullets are going to come
through your
window or when is the next drive-by
or or is your mama or your daddy going
to get
arrested there's no time to play
but a guy came into my room once a guy
from the burns institute
and he's under he is researching
why are youth of color so
overrepresented
in california youth correctional
facilities why are
black youths maybe 11.5 of the
california population yet they represent
52 of the population of incarcerated
youth
why why is that so they came into my
gymnasium once
and they saw black and latino youth
skipping across the floor acting like a
melancholic elephant
or a joyful leopard or a
confused dove or a drunk squirrel
and you create a space
of trustworthiness and where everything
that is said within that group is sacred
and there's no wrong answer and nothing
is wrong
and you create the space and then the
magic comes then they they
open up but the first day is really just
about icebreakers can
can i share with you share with you one
story please do since we were talking
earlier about animals and
um in in my work with i did a couple
films with the ute mountain you tribe
the members of the you not you tribe in
colorado
and i had a lot of talks about the
relationship between human beings and
the animal kingdom
so in this last workshop
at camp baffleball i noticed the kids
were like really really
standoffish and really distant and doing
a lot of this like what no i
can't be he's not serious this guy's a
fake
and a rattlesnake entered our room
and it was all cold up and it was like
ready to
bite anybody who came near it and um one
of the kids wanted to kill i said no no
no don't kill the snake
because the snake doesn't understand
where where he's at
he's in a gymnasium in a youth
correctional facility he needs to be in
the bushes or underground
so we we worked together and took the
rattlesnake and
put him over the fence so he would get
away and i
asked the kids i said why do you think
that ralph snake came in he said ah i
was confused i said well
you are the rattlesnake and they said
what do you mean i said because you guys
are all called up like this
and suspicious of us i said i'm not i'm
not criticizing you i'm just making an
observation
i said i'm coiled up too because i don't
know if you're going to trust me
so we're all called up and like rattling
but we're not getting anything done so
can we let the so then we did an
exercise where we were rattlesnakes
and then i said let's act like really
trusting rattlesnakes and they all stop
rattling so i thought that was sometimes
the universe reflects
what it is we're going through when
we're working with other people
in the middle on the the midpoint see
saturday would be
day seven um a california brown
tarantula
entered the gymnasium and the kids got
scared i said hey it's a california
brown tarantula they will not bite you
they're not venomous they're they're
harmless so i picked it up and my
instructor tyson picked it up i said
look it's not
it looks scary but it's not the kid said
oh that's just like us like
a lot of people out there think we're
dangerous and we're going to hurt them
but we're not we just
want to have enough to eat and we want
to love and be loved and
we're not always dangerous you know so
that was another example of
the universe reflecting what was going
on between
instructors students and the last day
this is amazing the last day
never had this happen i've never had any
animal visitations
um during our workshops but on the last
day we were filming the last take
and not one and not two but three deer
come up
to the phantom look at us and
i said cut cut and i said let's look at
the deer
it's what are the deer what are they
doing here i said i've never had deer
come up to me i've done eight workshops
at effort ball
so what do you think why are the deer
here i don't know they like film making
you know like well there's something
deeper than that i think as animals we
animals pick up on they have that sick
sense
they don't have a lot of the luggage we
have as humans what are they saying
and i said let's look at in the deer's
eyes and one of the kids said oh um
they like the fact that we're doing
something productive and good i said
you're right i said they're reflecting
back
on your focus and
when the deer came two of them left but
one sat down until we finished and just
watched us and wow
it created this um feeling
of of acceptance and gentleness
and empathy because deer are very gentle
so that's something to be noted and i
actually talked about in the doc how
we had a rattlesnake visit on day one a
california brown transfer visit in the
midpoint
and the last day the deer came and i
also feel like the deer helped get the
youth to that place
to connect with their empathy because
they said wow the deer look really
friendly like they look like loving like
they care about us i'm like yeah that's
the nature of deer
and it got them to think about what
what part of me can be like a deer
how can i be loving or or sympathetic or
be interested in someone else's
well-being
there's the three i believe it was the
three deer that were very instrumental
in getting my students to that place
i mean i've never had animal visitations
i had three rattlesnake california brown
translated deer
you cannot ignore these things now
people think i'm kind of out there but i
i pay attention to this right right
again the synchronicity is these signs
yep whether it's just that you're
noticing them and other people don't
i think most people they're too busy
with the phone they're looking at the
latest like celebrity baby news or
something or
you know political scandal and and to
being open to seeing that
were you always this empathetic though
or was this a a long process
um yeah i've been empathetic but i think
working with this population just
expanded my capacity for that you know
and i also think a life-changing thing
for me was doing the two films with the
ute mountain you tribe i
i um
i have a medicine man his name is
wayland plenty holes
and um we were having some really
weird stuff happen we were shooting in
the youth shelter
and there was a lot of really dark stuff
happening like people
having negative thoughts people having
um being overcome with anxiety
um people becoming someone they weren't
people breaking out in hives and i
called my medicine manner i said
i need you to please help me and um he
came in
and did a blessing with the red willow
red willow brook bark
and sage and i i asked my medicine man i
said what
what um what was going on in that set i
said it was there was some
negative energy he said where you're
filming
many youth were abused many youth
committed suicide
and there's a lot of negative energy
around here so you were feeling that so
i had to have the medicine man come and
clean up
the space every day before he filmed he
taught me a lot about
animals and how they communicate with us
and i think that opened my eyes to
i don't know it it just helped to expand
my awareness all my conversations with
folks from the the mountain you travel
and the other
since you're talking about synchronicity
my my tia you can use this or not use it
but
maitia my aunt told me before i went to
colorado
three years ago she said you're going to
have a hard time
this is going to be very challenging
thing because life on the res is really
tough
it's really it's really hard for me to
talk about because i don't like
seeing young people anyone suffer so she
said you will have an ally it would be
you will have a male ally that will help
you overcome the negative forces and
i figured oh my ally is
chief heart um
it's definitely the chief because i get
along well with him and he's powerful
and he has he's like a shaman
so when this incident happened we were
shooting on the youth shelter i
i called the medicine man i said i don't
know what to do there's some rich stuff
going on here and i
either have i can't cancel the shooting
i can't because we're not going to
finish the film i need
you to please come and help me
understand what's going on so my
my tea has said you'll have an ally and
he will walk in two complete
counterclockwise
circles with you and i said really she
said yes that's
you have an ally and you will know who
it is when he walks in two complete
counterclockwise circles so when when
waylon came
we had to sit in a circle and we we
smoked red willow bark and we smoked
sage
and we had to turn the pipe
counterclockwise that we passed it
around
then he said i need everyone to walk
with me in one circle
so we walked in one counterclockwise
circle and i said to myself
that's not him he's not my ally because
he's younger than me you know he's like
32.
he's like nah it's not him it's it's
chief heart
so um on the last day of um
my on my last day in colorado i was told
that when you ask
a medicine man or a minister woman for
help they can't say no
even if you are their enemy they cannot
say no also they cannot charge for it
they don't understand like how in
western culture you have to charge to
see a doctor or charge to see a
therapist
or tries to see a psychiatrist because
they believe that if you have a gift to
heal
you heal you do not charge for it
so i figured okay i can't give him money
so i'm gonna buy gifts for all his kids
so i went to his house
and gave the house kids they made me a
really beautiful lunch and
he said before you leave before you head
to the airport i'd like to show you my
my my property and he
said let's go and his wife and
three kids left and um we walked around
the property in a complete
counter-clockwise circle
and i said you're my ally
i said i apologize because i rejected
you as my ally
because you're younger than me but you
really are a medicine man and so we're
good friends now i call him for advice
sometimes he's the one to help me
understand the snake in the
california branch ransom the deer so
that experience
i had with the folks at the mountain you
tribe helped to expand
open my eyes to what's out there there's
another realm out there that we don't
know about you talked earlier about a
higher hand
so that really helped me to evolve also
helped me to evolve
as a filmmaker because on that um the
day before
the event at the youth shelter uh a man
from the apache tribe came up and said
do you know what you were doing with the
young native american youth here i said
yes
he said what are you doing i said i'm
teaching the filmmaking he said what
else are you doing
i said i'm teaching them storytelling he
said what else are you doing i said i'm
empowering them he said
there's something else you're doing
there's a prophecy with the indigenous
people there's 566
native american tribes in north america
but all the indigenous tribes from
around the world believe
that this generation right now 18 and
under
they are the seventh generation that's
the generation that is going to wipe out
discrimination inequality
human suffering and so he said when you
teach
young people you are preparing
the seventh generation to heal the world
and that made me recontextualize my
approach to how i teach so
when i went to afroball i said hey these
kids okay they made bad decisions
but they are going to be healers walking
this
earth according to the seventh
generation prophecy you're not hearing a
lot about it
but it's coming more into mainstream
thinking a lot of these new companies
called seventh generation but so to
think rethink my role as not just
teacher or film teacher but nurturing
and cultivating protecting their gifts
so that they can't go on
and make the changes in the world that
we want may not happen but it's going to
be their generation
and this is the 7th generation prophecy
in 2016 you interviewed with the site la
taco i love that site by the way
and they have a great instagram and you
said that about los
angeles there's a taut tension here
which does not exist in any other city
in the world
la right now is experiencing a burst of
radical creativity
being in the media arts or other genres
is an exciting time to be in los angeles
now this was in 2016
right so i'm wondering what the tension
is that doesn't exist in other cities
and then if you can also talk about the
creativity yeah it's hard to
it's hard to like find um a name for it
but so
look i work a lot berlin there's
attention there but it's it's more
there's a lid on it right new york
there's attention
um but there's no there's a feeling to
la
that la offers that no other city hasn't
i don't when i say taut tension it's not
in a negative
way it's just that there's so many
different cultures buttressed up against
each other
you know and we're understanding now
that we need to not only
co-exist and cohabitate but we need to
get along to make
our community safer and better and
stronger
but also there's a lot of
experimentation going on whether it be
at
cal arts or pasadena arts center
i just think that the generation of
artists the new generation of artists
they're really
bored with everything old and that's
been done
and i see a lot of radical um
trailblazers you drive around la and you
see people making films or painting
murals
or or taking photos or doing spoken word
out in the public this
these bursts of creativity i feel like
there's a
something smoldering smoldering beneath
our feet in l.a because we keep
and even physically like i live in
downton la
every month there's a new business open
or a new building or some new
construction it just keeps
changing and changing and changing and i
just feel like in la
it's it's more like
an open frontier especially in terms of
the media arts the people are taking
so many chances and trying new things
whereas i feel like
cities like new york are more like stuck
in old school
new york where they believe in the
formality of cinnamon the formality of
arts where l.a
this is where experimentation is going
on and i think a lot of it comes from
the tension
you drive down venice boulevard and you
go
you know you go through a high-income
neighborhood then you go to koreatown
then you go through a low-income
neighborhood then you see
korean-americans then latinos then
african-americans
and then you know more more white folks
and then to the beach where it's really
white and uppity but
it's that tension the the combining
of different people from different
backgrounds
different cultures different classes
that create something really really
exciting you know and right now there's
a lot of tension in downtown l.a because
and i i when i write down skid row right
i am not able to reconcile
what i see with what i was told america
was
my parents or grandparents the suffering
young mothers spoon feeding their kids
baby food on the curb when it's raining
outside
this is wait this is not america i still
cannot numb myself to that but what's
going on is
la wants all the homeless gone by the
time the
olympics come in 2020 where are they
going to go
where so where are they going to go
they're feeling
pushed out they're feeling expendable
and they're feeling unloved
and they're angry and there's this
there's this really concentrated tension
right now indefinitely
because the homeless people resent the
people who have
sure and the haves resent the people who
have not because
there's some sanitation issues sure but
there there's there's a real tension in
downton la
where you have the homeless people have
been there for generations
and you have this new influx of socially
economically upwardly mobile people and
there's a clash
but there's got to be a way where we if
we can spend three billion dollars
on a rover to put on mars can't we
figure out this homeless situation
what what what what how do we how do we
make this work so
there's so many la's changing every day
and that's what causes the tension and
there's so many
competing needs but i would rather we
look at
what do we all have in common we all
want to love and be loved we all want to
have a roof over our head
we want to have enough money to put food
on the tables and educate ourselves
can we focus on those things but
it's there's a lot of tension right now
definitely i'm actually glad to be
in in the middle of it but i feel like
uh werner herzog is a director yeah he's
great
he wrote an essay on la and he said la
is the most exciting place to be
and will be the most exciting city to be
in the world for the next 50 years
because of this experimentation and
taking chances
i just i don't know what it is exactly i
can't pinpoint it but
there's something exciting happening
there's this renaissance of
new art it's past post modern
people are anxious to tell stories their
way
without being tied into
the hollywood substructure and there's
this new freedom
to tell stories our way and make films
our way
without being tied into the hollywood
studio or
hollywood network system because you can
shoot a film on the phone now
that the freedom that gives you you
don't have to go to film school
and get a grant a camera and rent and
get a grip and a gap you can go out and
make a film with the phone
that freedom allows a whole
new bandwidth of cinematic creativity
and i'm really excited by it does that
answer the question
it does did you see the documentary city
of angels no it was about homeless
homeless in l.a i heard of that it was
narrated by
catherine keener together kathleen
catherine kane it was excellent it's
very sad but
just humanized all of them and told
their stories
you know and um
yeah that's all i have to say but but
see they they have their stories too and
here's my thing um i had a i have a
mentor who
would say doesn't um believe in
organized religion but he he said look
this is earth
these are the people and this is god
we're all connected my feeling is this
so
if there's a community um that's
suffering like let's say the homeless
people are really suffering
because they're they're they're
compressing the size of
skid row and the the population of skid
row has almost doubled in the last
four years so you have more people in a
smaller space competing for resources
so my argument is this so um so if your
hand is cut
and you get gangrene let's say you have
a cut that's infected it affects your
whole body
and you have to treat that hand
otherwise the infection is going to
spread
so so when there's a community that's
suffering and is in pain
and is not well it affects all of us
they are
part of the family of humanity
so you some people may not
perceive the homeless people and the
mentally challenged people as
an inconvenience and as unsanitary
and as unwelcome but they're still
human beings and if we don't take care
of them
we all suffer and i'm i'm concerned
because i don't know where these people
are going to go when la olympics come
well i i don't know how true this is but
i
heard that during another la olympics
they just bust them to outskirts of la
that weren't as populated again it's
just a rumor
but um
yeah i don't know what the easy answer
is i mean i guess
the problem is when people say well we
offer them housing and they don't want
it
and i understand because there probably
are some pretty strict rules with that
and maybe not everybody's meant to fit
into
a certain box and maybe it's too much
for some of them who've been used to
being so free
and i guess the hard part is is that
you know the sanitation thing i mean i
don't know if there's a way to offer
just a public
restroom and i i realized and who's
gonna
be paid to clean it and and take care of
that i mean santa monica
has a public park that's great it's
clean everybody can use it and they do
an amazing job at keeping it clean
um but yeah i i hear you on that one it
is it is hard and i've seen a lot of
people not just
homeless but what they call rubber
tramps or whatever that that are in
their um
you know their rvs and stuff there's a
huge community of that
i actually think there's a there's a
radical opportunity for us to
to lead them to a place of inclusion and
belonging like why couldn't someone come
up with an idea where
let's hire homeless youth and help them
build these new olympic facilities
if we're going to create a village for
international athletes coming from
every country from around the world why
could we create a village
for formerly homeless people to live in
the village and just
work on creating venues or or
creating putting art up around the city
for the olympics let's let's get them
involved
can we get them involved and create job
opportunities and
while they are working can we teach them
skills that will allow them to become
employable after the olympics leave
you know but that's another tension
because
you can't when you sweep something under
the carpet
because la wants everyone to think there
are no homeless people here well guess
what there are
you keep sweeping something under the
carpet every day
it becomes this big mountain that people
just trip over
and it's also a lie it's facade it's not
yeah
it's not real so i'm hoping that the
leaders
of la county and city of la
figure out a way to solve this without
pushing people out that really feel a
sense of belonging in l.a
i'm really hoping that they will be up
for that challenge even though you're
from the bay area
but somehow you've found your belonging
here in la
which is interesting because i'm also
from the bay area and i know the bay
area
has a lot of negative thoughts about la
i don't always see it in the reverse
i don't always see angelino's like oh
that bay area they're so flighty and
nobody and this that maybe they say they
don't i don't know i but i don't see as
much of reverse
so i just find it interesting that
you've embraced la even though you're
from the bay area
yeah there's a bad stigma when it comes
to people in hollywood like
my my dad came to an event of mine and a
colleague of mine brought his girlfriend
who's an actress
and they were at this party i threw
after one of my screens and
my colleague's girlfriend um was very
attractive my dad was taking a picture
of her
because he just wanted a picture of her
because he thought oh maybe she's a
famous actress and she looked at him and
said i didn't tell you you could take a
photo of me
i'm a sag actress do you have my
permission
where's my release form oh you're nobody
you're nobody to me and so
my dad was really upset and i went up to
this woman i said you cannot talk to him
like that that's my dad
and she goes oh i'm so sorry i said you
should not talk to anyone like that
and i kicked you out of the party i said
i don't want people like that who would
treat
not just my father but anyone like that
and she went to meet me but since then
my
parents don't want to come back to see
my screenings because of this
this is stuff like this happens and it
gets back to the baby
you know yeah i mean we interviewed this
couple
um mark and elaine zuccree and they said
there's a good hollywood
and a bad hollywood and i think that
that's the case
maybe not a lot of gray area but i think
that that's the case yeah
and it's trying to find those that are
in the hollywood that you want to belong
to
and so you know it's different when
you're making indie films because you
kind of want to think well i'm not in
hollywood but there is an
industry sort of personality and we're
all fragile and we're all
like trying to get our message out there
trying to get our work out there
so that creates certain things i get it
and um
but yeah that's well that's that's not a
good story
yeah there is a good and a bad side but
unfortunately my
it really put a really
distasteful it was a very bad experience
for my dad and they're they're now
not interested in coming down when i
have a film that comes out i
go up there to screen it for them
because of that experience
well what's interesting is that they you
know they're the argument of that
hollywood's morals are bad
and the message that messages that they
put out okay i agree
with some of the films when they try to
do these like positive
certain films they might be too squeaky
clean for some people to really relate
to
so i feel like there's not enough of a
middle ground
with some of the i get why you know
hollywood could be branded
not smut peddlers but i mean for lack of
a better word okay
or or to to cookie cutter um
i guess there's not enough of a middle
ground for the for the for the positive
messages
it seems like it's too squeaky clean
it's not real but but but i do
i do have a hard time relating i'm not
saying i'm better than anybody but i do
find difficulty relating to people who
are in the industry because they want to
be rich or famous i
i i want to tell stories and
um i want people to feel something deep
and profound
and my other hope is that like in the in
the work i do with
incarcerated youth to see how they shine
like this is a
a segment of a population that is so
misunderstood
um i'm hoping that my films will help
contribute to
the elevation of a collective human
consciousness about wow we're really
really the same these kids aren't that
bad i messed up i believe
people deserve a second chance i also
believe that forgiveness
is is freedom and i think people deserve
a second chance
what about these kids forgiving
themselves even if it wasn't
their fault for something whether it was
just the family they were born into
do you ever go into that yeah we do you
know it's interesting because the youth
typically make films based on their own
personal or immediate history and when
they see
scenes from their own personal lives
played out on a big screen with an
audience of 100 to 200 people
and people relating to their story and
then getting an applause
um i'm not a psychotherapist or
psychoanalyst but
by making films about their immediate
past it renders the past unrepeatable
they gained perspective like oh why did
i do that why did i have two babies
mamas like
oh i guess i wasn't thinking and they
begin to think critically about their
own lives and it helps them gain
perspective on their lives
and we talk about well like the law of
physics to every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction to every action
you take there's a consequence
so you have to slow down and think about
what are the consequences of this this
is something i
took up on zen meditation um so then
meditation and one thing i'm learning is
um not not reacting
when when someone when you when you
sense conflict
you don't just react you listen and you
be like that bamboo
that bamboo tree which the roots go very
deep and the wood is so strong termites
can either bend
with the wind but never break never
break never break i talk about that with
the youth
and get them to think critically about
their lives so they do begin to um
i always say you know it if you spend
almost your life
regretting what you did you're not going
to actually be present in life
but they do get to that place after they
see their films
alex how much are you sacrificing your
own hollywood goals
to be so heavily involved with fyi films
or
did you never have hollywood quote
unquote hollywood goals
um yeah i have goals that are in
alignment with what how hollywood
perceives success but
um i don't feel like i'm sacrificing
anything because i feel like this
is my organic journey to being a
filmmaker
so i went to usc where we were very much
taught
a hollywood way of filmmaking you know
mise-en-scene master shot medium
close-up close-up
ecu cutaway you know and
um in working with the youth they're
very
informal like they don't like to lock
the camera down on a tripod because they
are locked up
they they're very inventive like one day
i came to the camp and
they attached um three bungee cords on
each side of the camera and said hey
munoz look it's a bungee cam and the
camera's moving
and they're very inventive and so
the way i was taught filmmaking was to
take a very stately formal hollywood
approach
the youth in working with the youth they
liberated me from that and i become more
radical in my approach to storytelling
through cinema i crossed the line we
told never cross the sagittal plane
while i do all the time now because the
youth
involved in me so i feel like my work
with them
is a necessary part of my journey i feel
like my work as a filmmaker is informed
by my
interactions and my making films with
them
the other thing they like is they don't
like
having to memorize lines and repeat
lines because it's too robotic for them
so before we shoot a scene with them
we'll say this is what's happening in
the scene you
want her to agree to date you
and you are saying no that is my sister
you're not dating her you don't want it
and i just freestyle it in free improv
so it's made me a little bit more
relaxed i use improvisation a lot
i didn't before i started working with
this population i'm more relaxed
um and and and and less formal and it's
interesting because when i
when i place um so many pitchers
entertainment they um support us and
they give us cameras and when we give
cameras to the youth um the first thing
they do is they point
cameras back at the surveillance camp
saying i see you
you're watching me but i'm watching you
watch me you know they take control
of the aprons and they turn the tables
but when they're filming
they'll i'll say go to what interests
you they'll go to where the emotion is
like if there's a scene between a son
and an actress who's the mother crying
to go into the teardrop going down the
mothers
i and it's a very organic approach they
go to where
they feel the emotional power is what
what is interesting in the scene
oh the mother really feels bad that she
wasn't the mother she should have been
the first 14 years of his life
and it's it's a necessary part they're
making me a better filmmaker
my work with them and forms my path so
my next project
it's a feature film called make the moon
it was developed at sundance years ago
and um it's based on my my twin brother
and i growing up
in san jose and it focuses on a mother
um
who has um two sons that are mixed race
i also have a sister and a brother but
i'm focusing
on my twin brother and i for this but in
this film
there are three young people
that really impress me as actors uh one
is a young woman from the ute mountain
you tribe two others are from l.a
they're in the film i'm casting them
then there's six other youth that are
going to work on the film and i'm going
to pay them
and they're going to learn what it's
like to be on an independent film set
and they're going to continue to develop
their skills as filmmakers so
this is in alignment with both um i am
going after my hollywood goal making
this feature film but i'm also engaging
formerly incarcerated youth
so i'm combining the two and
my dream is to i'm currently working on
a plan
i'd like to open up a film academy in
the next three to five years
and the film academy would be kind of
like the homeboy industries of
filmmaking
to ex-gang members youth who have been
affected by the foster care system
youth affected by the juvenile justice
system not only train them to work on
on music video commercial or tv sets or
movie sets
but to create develop and make their own
content
because they have a different take on
things
so to me the real exciting stuff is
happening in the margins
they're not part of mainstream media
they're not part of mainstream society
they have their
own secret called the language of how to
tell a story with film
they don't do the master shot medium
close-up close-up issue they'll just get
shot get the shot get this out
of her cry let's move on you know
and they they love that they use their
own language
to to um take ownership
like a slate they don't call slate to
slate they call it a shield
and i asked this kid jimmy why do you
call it a shoot oh in case bullets come
through he could dodge the bullets
a company move when you move the cast
and the crew they call it in
trans that's when a youth is being
transported from a correctional facility
to the court
go to hearing okay they don't see
say quiet on the set they said they say
quiet in the ghetto or quiet on the
vario and they also said
don't say it's mls just say it's nfs
null
friggin sound so they they come up with
their own vernacular
on language to allow them to take
ownership but it's this
very informal radical approach to
filmmaking
that inspires me and informs me so
they're actually helping me
unlearn what usc taught me which is very
formal hollywood
just because you're being taught that
doesn't mean that's the only way to make
films
so my films i feel now are more
[Music]
alive and more expressive
because i let go some of that old skull
training you know
they're very radical with the camera
they do things like turn it upside down
and
do cartwheels with it whilst there's a
chase scene
and it's that type of approach that that
informs my
current approach to filmmaking just like
you said that some of the
quote unquote not worth students but
maybe most
arms crossed resistant turn out to be
some of the best do you think that's the
same in
quote traditional film schools the some
of the worst students
maybe you know in the back yeah
who is this and then actually they turn
out to be the best
yeah did you know do you know the story
about jim morrison
at usc sort of yeah yeah he did he did
two films and
people said you have no you don't have
one creative molecule in your body what
are you doing here
he was making some i actually saw two of
the films they were in the usc archive
and they're really really interesting
and of course he went on to be in the
doors
but um um you know i went to a film
school that was very entrenched in
you know traditional conventional
hollywood film storytelling
and what i'm trying to express is that
that's good it's important to know that
but the youth offered a different
approach to filmmaking which i find much
more exciting
and much more real and gets audiences to
react more
you know they also don't believe in
these
unrealistic fake they call it fake ass
delusional endings where everything's
fine because
sometimes everything doesn't end fine
but you keep going
one of my students um fila said you know
sometimes things don't end well but
maybe the next situation will end well
and you just hope that things end well
and you you celebrate it
when stories end well when they don't
end well
you think about what happened and you
learn from it and you grow from it and
you move on
so in the films we do they're not all
these you know
neatly tied up endings because that's
not the way life is
right it's not sometimes things don't
become resolved
no i don't you might have a fallout with
a cousin or a family member
and that you may spend the rest of your
life going back and forth
thinking that it's going to get there
but it doesn't that's what life is
us trying to love and be loved and
also pay the bills and feed ourselves
and
experience warmth and joy right and
yeah go good the lemley as much as you
can yes great movies yeah yeah
and by the way lonely didn't have to say
that but yeah they do have some great
movies and one the beauty of our house
cinema is that
oftentimes things don't always there's
an ambiguous emptying or it's not always
perfect whereas
other theaters might be more neatly tied
up and i can see how they would
relate to that there's a film two latino
youth made a film called family problems
in um
it was a young latino man who made a
film about his mother who was
um what they called a glass head
addicted to crystal meth and um
one of the boys julio said hey munoz
this film
is about alan's mom but he doesn't want
you to know but don't say anything
he said okay i won't so the next day
ally came up to me and said hey munoz
this film about this mother who's like
addicted to meth
that's about julio's mom but he doesn't
want you to know
well both the mothers were addicted to
to meth
and so we made this film and in the film
the boy is begging the mother to go into
rehab he finally
gets the courage to say mom please go
into rehab and she does go to rehab in
the film
so both boys invited their mothers to
the film and i said if you invite your
mothers to this film
it's really unfair if you don't tell
them what the film is about
you have to tell them because they might
experience shame
they might experience rage humiliation
or anger
we cannot drop a bomb on your moms we
have to let them know so i called
their mothers and the boys were on the
phone with me i said look
um this is what the film is about um
are you comfortable seeing a film about
a young boy who wants his mom to go into
rehab both agreed
they wanted to watch the film both went
this is at the sony theaters
saw the film broke down into tears
within 48 hours both mothers
were in rehab oh wow because
it took a film made by their sons
and they saw their son saying mama mama
i need you mama i need you
you need to stop using and you need to
go to rehab i love you no matter what
but
i need you in my life i need a mom so
the films not only affect the individual
but also the family and the community
and so even things like that the films
were so
real so my demand for authentic
representation
it's much more pronounced because of my
students
i don't like fake stuff this has no
resonance
you know can you give us five filmmaking
tips for anyone who wants to make a
movie
first of all have a good screenplay
that's the most important thing
have a good screenplay number two
make sure you have the resources to make
the film
don't rush into making the thumb unless
you have the resources to pay
for the the camera equipment the
locations and
personnel um the third one is have a
really good producer who knows what they
are doing
and be very very selective in who you
hire
so have a good script
have the resources to make the film hire
a really really good producer
be polite and respectful and grateful
to every crew member and cast member
very very very important and one way you
can show gratitude is by feeding people
well
keep keep the morale up and um
number five be open to um suggestions if
an actor
i did a film with rana owen really great
actors from
um once we're warriors and um
she's on another plane i mean
her her acting is she's it's she's not
it's not rennet owen it's the character
it's it's amazing
and so i would block things out and she
would say well i was thinking omar would
do it this way
i said yes you're right let's do it you
have to be open
don't let your ego get in the way of the
process because that will really mess
you up
if you're working with an actress that
has been acting like for 30 40 years and
you've been directing for five years
listen to that actress
so be open to taking guidance or
suggestions
because it will make your film better
what was the biggest mistake you made in
the beginning on a film set
oh so i directed a music video
for a company called oral factory and
i gotta sign the cinematographer i
didn't get to pick him
and um i would ask him to um
do something and he wouldn't do it
and he just i would say shoot it this
way and he would shoot it another way
and the mistake i made was i didn't
stand up for my vision
i said well i guess this is what i have
to do i was just at a film school i'm
like i guess
well he's an ass i guess sometimes you
have to work with asses
but the music video did not end up being
a good video why
because he had no interest in executing
my vision
and i don't know what this guide was
about
but the mistake i made was not standing
up for my vision
in front of everybody i was too shy
about it you know
um and i'll never make that i'll never
make that mistake again
the same thing um well i won't talk
about that
but you have to defend your vision you
must
defend your vision and if there's
someone that is not
helping you execute the vision cut them
off
because the video was a nightmare
but i learned from it that will never
happen again
what has contributed to your success so
far whether it's
watching something else someone else
seeing how they work
liking their style making mistakes
learning from them
belief in yourself meditation what do
you think has kept you i mean you've
been doing this i'm sorry with fyi 17
yeah years ago 15 years 15 years
and you've been making films previously
you went to film school you went to two
film schools right no i went to one usc
oh ufc okay
what do you think's contributed to you
staying in the game because not
everybody
stays with this some people could make
one film they go to sundance they want
an award and then
either they can't find funding for the
next project and they walk away or they
get tired of it it's a lot of work
you're going to get beat up i think it's
um
in in my course of working with
incarcerated youth
they've taught me the the power of
storytelling
it's really really really powerful
you know just the story for instance of
so a young black man who was one of my
students
while he was at chem gazelle has made a
film about him going home
and his fear about his father rejecting
him again his father always rejected him
right so
he made a film about this young black
man who goes home and the mother
is trying to make everything fine but
the father says get out of here i don't
want you in this house you're a juvenile
delinquent i don't want you here
but i want nothing to do with you so
this protagonist has to go through being
rejected yet again
by his father right so this is we
this was after the the film i talked
about about the mother who was
had substance abuse issues right and so
um
we invited the family to see the film
and i told antoine i said you got it you
have to tell your dad what the film is
about because
it can make him really ashamed or
uncomfortable you can't you can't just
do this to your dad so i talked to the
dad explained what it was
said yeah yeah whatever i'm just i don't
even want to go i'm just going because
my wife wants me to go so he went
and he saw this very tearful film about
a young boy who just would do
anything anything to be accepted and
loved by his father
the father was in tears
and i realized this is the power of film
like
but what's what's more beautiful about
the story is that
um the mother called me a week later and
they went to family therapy to talk
about this stuff so
so this is how authentic storytelling
can lead
to healing
very interested in doing what i can to
contribute to the well-being of humans
whether they're in
angola or japan or the project itself
film has that power that the father and
the son
began a dialogue about how that
relationship could be healed and
repaired
all because he came up with this idea so
what keeps me going is
stories like this seeing how films and
stories
impact and heal people
that's what keeps me going have you ever
wanted to give up
yes when they pulled the plug of my film
in lake county probation i was like wow
i just had all these dark thoughts but
my alumni my alum called me you know
from mexico saying
i got deported but i'm teaching
filmmaking to incarcerated youth and
that kept me going again so see they
made
maybe i've lifted them when i'm i'm with
them but they call me
out of the blue sometimes and they lift
me
imagine that so and adrian getting me to
stevie wonder i was like oh i'm never
gonna make this film
so there's an exchange yes i'm teaching
them about filmmaking
teaching them to think critically about
their lives but they're teaching me too
they were embolding me
they're giving me permission to go
outside of what i learned at usc
get more radical and tell stories that
have power because they're authentic
to tell tell stories that will
hopefully challenge people to to find a
place of healing
you know that's what keeps me going
because the impact
powerful stories have on individuals
you've written a script that you said
was at sundance
you were working on it at one of the
labs can you talk about that
yeah it's it's make the moon and it's
about a um
[Music]
it's semi-autobiographical but it's
about a a a mother i'm mixed race my
mother is caucasian and uh
it's about a single mom who's caucasian
she has two
she has identical twin sons and the
father was not white
and um she loves one twin
she loves him because he's good i'm
bringing my own spot here
he's good in the arts he's good at
sports he he's very communicative she
loves him
she feels that he is going to be the
first of my family to go to college
the other son is involved in gangs
smoking weed getting ghosts pregnant
and dropping you know not showing up to
school
um the one that she really loves
ends up tragically died in an accident
and the surviving twin she forces him
to become the twin she loves she said
you be
your brother then i can love you because
i'm not doing that
it's a film about grief and about broken
relationships
so it's intense you wrote it years ago
yeah i wrote it um about
nine years ago and i i've avoided it
because
it's too close to home but
i'm in a place now because i talked
about my um
experience working with the youth
mountaineer tribe and these very
truthful conversations about
our mortality um
and my father was diagnosed with colon
cancer um two years ago
i went home on christmas eve and they
had to take 90 of his calling out and uh
i um had to change his dressing so he
had an incision from his
belly button up here and i had to reach
in
and that too had i started thinking i
don't know i'm not ready to lose my dad
like i don't want
i even though i don't see things the way
my parents do i don't want to lose my
parents yet
and i don't want to leave this place yet
but i
facing the possibility of my father
dying made me
think of my own mortality like i got to
tell these stories i got to get this
film done
and get out of my phobic vortex
about dealing with the truth and get
this thing done
so as painful as it is
i was dwelling on how hard it is but now
i'm looking at how therapeutic it is i'm
going to be liberated when i tell the
story
because releasing a story to universe
can be very very
you know liberating so i'm at a place
now where i'm ready
to get it done as a matter of fact i'm
going to um
one of my founders to get a check for
half the amount of the budget
oh wow i'm ready to do the film
and i'm glad i haven't done the film yet
because if i did the film earlier
it would lack truth and power because of
what i went through
and i just think that you have to trust
the continuum
and a lot of artists get into these dark
spaces when we're not working
we're not on the set or we're not
writing or we don't have a deadline
um i look at that time
my friend alex dorsey shared something
with me she said in those in between
moments where you have downtime
you are preparing your chalice
for future wine that's a very healthy
way of looking at it right
you are preparing your challenge for a
future wine
when did you start writing make the moon
oh i started writing make the moon in
high school
um i knew i would be telling a very
personal story it's a
kind of a coming-of-age story um
the film is basically about a mother and
son
who
no matter how hard they try they can't
seem to love one another
and as painful as that is it's true
sometimes happens between child and
parent
um in the end of the film there is
definitely a sign of hope but i'm not
gonna have some ending and have
mother and son
wrap their arms around each other oh
i've always loved you i'm sorry it's
just
so it's it's about a mother and son
who are locked in grief which
complicates
their desire to really truly love each
other and no matter how hard they try
the harder they try to love each other
the further apart they get
that's how loaded it is you know with
family sometimes
and so the script you've been working on
for years when did you actually get it
in like
first draft second draft and a beyond
stage
how was that i have like 18 different
versions and
one version was 198 pages long and
um so i had to step away from it um
i i have so many different drafts but
now i'm at a draft that's 112 pages
and that's that's that's what i want to
go with i want to go
with 112 minute film
and will you shoot it here in l.a yes i
was gonna shoot it in san jose the
original title was do you know the way
to san jose
but um the texture in la the locations
the tension that we talked about that's
all here
um i've done a lot of research um i'm
actually breaking
i'm dividing la into three different
realms and this is probably informed by
my experience with the youth mountaineer
trap there's the
the utter welt the underworld there's
the surface world right the streets and
then there's the
uberwell the overworld so there's three
different realms to l.a
so it's kind of spiritual because the
people who are like you know
doing naughty things and doing illegal
stuff that hide underground that's the
dark
underworld and the surface world which
most of us are
are in and then the overworld which is
more the superior beings
there's a character named haika she
lives in a treehouse and the birds and
the butterfly is always around her
because she's of the overworld
um so la that was a big choice to to um
have it take place in l.a the other
thing i worry about is
it's a it's a um
it's the type of film that some people
may be upset by because i choose to be
real
and i don't and there's some really
radical scenes that might elicit some
very negative reactions especially
people from the christian right
and i don't want my family to be
mistreated or or um
disrespected because a member of their
family made this film
doing it to protect my family it's not a
faith-based film
right no it's quote unquote faith okay
but it's there there's
um spirituality questions
yes okay that doesn't conform to you
know i was born and raised catholic
definitely it's not anti-catholic it's
just it's a different way of
this young man this protagonist has a
different way of looking at things and
he meets a woman named haika who helps
them understand
relationships and families and it's
otherworldly it's just
you speak german i speak german yeah
where did you learn german
it cabi d'orskillet and hochschild and
actu uni
um i learned to speak in high school and
college and i studied in
in berlin yeah but i oh you went to
berlin okay yeah last time i was in
berlin i was directing a show and
um i meant to tell an actress du musti
um
coulee upbringing i meant to say please
carry the pen when you enter the scene
i said please bring me your ass
[Laughter]
no i meant to order like we were offered
lunch and i meant to say
i'd like to order chicken which is dylan
i said it i said
i like to order a little puppy to eat oh
no so i think they just hire me because
i make them laugh
what's your favorite camera to shoot
with well i
the alexa the new alexa actually i
haven't shot with it yet but i want to
shoot with them because i've seen
uh dps um i've seen their dailies and
i've been sh i
love the red camera i love the red that
was my favorite camera but i'm going to
be shooting uh with the alexa for my
feature and i'm looking forward to that
oh you've already kind of planned that
yeah okay wow
and you'll be renting it yes oh okay do
you have like a place you go to you're
not to name it but that you rent
yeah a lot of your stuff you have a
really good dp i've been working with
him it's a francisco burrelli he's been
shooting for me for
about 12 years now so we have a really
good rapport and i let him do other
you know tell him what camera you want
and he goes out and gets it
what is important um for the director dp
relationship what do you think
because you know there are people they
just have their team what is that magic
that happens
i think um it's a
there has to be a space where you
co-share a similar sensibility
and a similar understanding of what
cinema is
in terms of using cinematography
to define tone and feel and
even rhythm and my suggestion to
filmmakers out there is if you are going
to go with the dp get to know that dp
take him out to lunch take him out to
coffee take him to happy hour take him
to dinner
hang out with him and see where his
sensibilities are
see what interests him in terms of you
know shooting images that when put
together assembled together make a story
you got to make sure that you have a
common language and you have a common
understanding of each other's
sensibilities
look like that music video i did for oil
factory the dp didn't listen to me
he was much older than me he just
thought it was some new kid which i was
and just did whatever he wanted and
rebelled against anything i wanted him
to do there was
no meeting between us
so you've gotta what really helps is if
if you have similar favorite films
that helps a lot i always ask people
what films do you like
from a cinematograph from a
cinematographer's point of view tell me
about films you really really like so
make sure there's a lot of common ground
between you and the cinematographer you
work
you work with what's been the easiest
year you've had as a filmmaker
and then what's been your toughest year
yeah i think my easiest year
was um
[Music]
it was uh 2000 when
i i booked my first film riot
the showtime film um i was brought in
under tragic
tragic circumstances the guy who wrote
it was um
joseph vasquez and he he passed away and
they were looking for
a new director and it turns out most of
the producers went to usc
and there was buzz about my my thesis
film called porvida
and um
i mean i did my first movie right when i
got out of film school and then i got a
commercial agent and i was doing
commercials
and my other film got into sundance it
was such a year
and yes there is some um happenstance
in um luck i don't like to call it luck
because someone died
but a writer director passed away they
needed someone to direct a segment i had
to come in and change it because the way
he wrote it he's from new york is
a brilliant writer director from new
york new eureka
and i had to make it more la but that
was a
i was thinking wow i just how did
this happen i'm directing a film for
showtime and i just got out of film
school
is this really happening and then i was
going to berlin and going to all these
film festivals so
but but the point of ignition was me
getting that showtime movie
and then the worst year was probably the
year i did i don't even like looking at
the film because the producers
um were not um
honest they cut out eight core scenes
and they said we're gonna shoot these
scenes
in um la and i said yeah let's shoot the
scenes because if we don't shoot these
eight scenes the story won't make sense
so
we wrapped the film we got to la and
they said we're not shooting those
scenes they never planned to shoot the
scenes
and they did shoot some additional new
scenes and i found out and
i told them i said you can't do this i'm
dga and
um i will report this to the union and
my dp said he's
he would report it also to his union
and they said well if you go to the
union we'll just drag your name through
the mud i said go ahead nothing's going
to come up
so i had to go to my union and and fight
just to
shoot some of the new scenes and i
almost reached the point of surrender
where i said to myself
i worked really hard to get into usc and
i worked really hard to to come up with
the money to pay
for my message to get my master's degree
why am i doing this
why am i going to spend six months of my
life on a film only to have it re-edited
and have stuff filmed behind my back
this is bs
but what i did instead is instead of i
just refused to
stand under the banner called victim
like i'm gonna learn from this and now
i'm a fiercely independent filmmaker i
gotta have final cut
and the films that have done well for me
my most award-winning films are films
where i have the final say in the
creative cup because
i know what i want i'm clear about my
vision but it was a bad year because
um i wanted to claim the alan smithey
clause which is if you don't like the
film and
if it deviates too much from your vision
you don't have to have your name on it
but if i took one name off of it i would
lose all the residuals and i needed the
money
so um not only did the film not do well
it didn't bomb it just was very very
lukewarm
and then i kind of got a little
blacklisted for running to the union and
people were i became a distant outpost
like no one wanted to really touch me
they were saying this guy we entered the
dj like a little baby and
people didn't really want to talk to me
or hire me
and that was a very tough year for me
but i recovered and you know we survive
we survive and we overcome and we keep
going
my auntie used to say onward ever
keep going this is a japanese proverb
it's um
follow down eight times get up nine
times
i have that above my wall above my desk
in my office
why do people fail in hollywood i
actually think more people
failed in hollywood than succeed because
it's
it's a game and what people don't
understand is the game changes every day
um
you have to know how the machine works
if you don't know how the machine
works you're not going to get your work
out there and you will not have
doors opening for your success and
i think also some people stumble and
fail
because they haven't taken the time
to develop their craft of storytellers
and filmmakers
you really have to have it down you
really have to know craft
you've got to know where to put the
camera what lens to use
what is the lighting what is the rhythm
tempo and pacing
what is being revealed in the scene
where is the climax where is the point
of ignition
where is the aftermath where does it
pick up again where does it end
you have to know these things otherwise
you're going to have a really hard time
making a
successful film it's craft craft craft
craft craft and the best way to learn
filmmaking
is go out and make films every time you
make a film you learn i'm still learning
i feel like i just scratched the surface
in terms of what it is what is it
to make a good film i like what you say
about um
the rules change hadn't really thought
of that that's really interesting so
how does somebody then start to know
what the rules are if no one's telling
you
but they're changing you have to
circulate and you have to read the
trades
you have to be informed you have to
gather intelligence um
i'm not going to mention names but
there's an actor who recently fell from
grace
and um he was attached to a project of
mine that project is now gone
because his fall was so
dark and tragic and severe and toxic
that
so the game changed from my relationship
with this actor because of what happened
it things are changing you know every
day
um i pitched a series to
a network that was ready to be greenlit
and the day we were supposed to sign the
papers
uh the channel hired a new person to
take over
and this new person said i'm not green
lighting any project that my predecessor
greenlit so i'm sorry
you have to piss this to someone else
changes had another tv show where i had
two very famous show runners
a week before we were supposed to go
sign the deal one of them got named
to run a network but you don't cry
in and weep about these things you go
okay this wasn't meant to be
let's keep going just keep going it
changes
every day it changes and you have to be
informed you have to
gather intelligence and talk to people
in the industry and read the trades
so besides this interview what else are
you doing for your filmmaking career
today
oh well like today um it's um
so i think that you know when you're
making a film my rule is that if you're
not laughing or joking around in my film
sit you can't work on my set because
when people are relaxed um it's like i
don't know if you ever
watched basketball but michael jordan
when he had the ball
and there was like three seconds left
and you knew he had to make a jump shot
his tongue would hang out and he
explained in his book that my if my
tongue is hanging out of my mouth that
means my body is relaxed
that means when my brain says make the
shot my body will do what the brain
signal
is but if i'm uptight i can't so
i shoot films every day on instagram
like today
it's my manager's birthday jane kell and
when the sun's at the right lighting
i asked two other clients of hers to
come and join me and we're gonna make
we're gonna make this short film to wish
your happy birthday it's still
filmmaking
oh that's sweet and i'm always if i see
something that interests me
and i have a moment i'll shoot a film
and here's another thing of advice the
new director's reel
is instagram uh
six of the last eight jobs i got were
because people saw my work on instagram
get your work out there it's not
facebook it's not a director's reel in
the link it's not a director's reel on a
dvd
people are looking at instagram i know a
lot of actors who get work
through instagram too everyone is
looking at instagram because it's very
visual
so i make little short films so you're
either uploading your video or you're
just
filming it with the camera to the
instagram video yeah
um i try to um because it can't be
more than 60 seconds so i try not to i
think
editing is important you know alfred
hitchcock did rope and
it had like zero editing but at the end
he said phil must be cut
he's like he didn't want to do it again
because it was good
but if you really want to um effectively
tell a story you're going to have to
edit
so for these films i do i usually have
one or two edits because they have to be
under 60 seconds
but you could tell the story in 60
seconds if
you think it through so yes i'm not
getting paid
i'm not on a set with a bunch of people
but i'm still directing i'm still
filmmaking
so i'm going to be doing a short film
like two hours from now downton la
for my manager who's the best person
you've ever worked with in hollywood
that's a that's a good question it's um
also loaded for me but
i'm gonna if you allow me to rephrase it
sure so i will share with you the person
who
most challenged me to become a better
director
so uh i directed a film called spout
which is this artsy vampire film
starring rena owen who is currently on
siren it's a great series about
um you know mermaids and she was she
gave an unforgettable performance
unforgettable performance in what's with
warriors and um
the reason why she challenged me to um
the reason why my working with her was
really transformative
is that
she taught me the importance of
preparation like i'm talking about
dogged preparation i'm talking about
like really
preparing every line of dialogue
and she also taught me what good acting
is
i really didn't know what good action
was until i
i met her and it's it's
it's magic and i only had to
um i only gave her direction three times
because we were talking about what was
going on the scene and she would deliver
and there were only three times in the
course of this film where i said oh can
you try it this way and she said yeah
that sounds good she did it and it
worked
but what she taught me was this when you
have an actor or actress who has given
you what
what you want stay out of the way
give them that space to to share their
gifts with your audience
give them space let them play give them
the freedom don't be
directing people like a traffic cop give
them the freedom to shine
and give them their space and let them
make choices
let them make radical choices
and let them play miranda taught me this
stuff
she taught me to be more relaxed and she
told me to trust my intuition
and trust my gut and ever since working
with her much more relaxed on set
but i'm also more demanding of my actors
in what way i push them more
i push them more where i'm not satisfied
with a good performance i want a great
performance and i used to coach football
i coached football
middle school football and my job being
a football coach was getting the best
performance out of my football players i
had to do that same thing when i'm on
the set
i got i got i need my actors to
achieve something they never thought was
imaginable as an actress or actor
rana taught me that she
i had a ceiling for what my expectations
were for my films and
for especially for my performances rena
said that ceiling is way too low alex
get rid of it this we can go much higher
together
if we relax and go by our instincts and
our guts and we
don't have anxiety and we prepare
because you know people have anxiety
when they do not prepare
if you looked at the debates the other
night not going to mention names but
there were certain candidates that were
not prepared and they had anxiety and
they were
stumbling and they weren't finishing
lines preparation is everything it's
another thing reyna owen taught me
so i'm a lot more dogged and a lot more
disciplined of a director because of
rena owen thank you rena
it